thanks for inviting me for the talk
today uh and i'll be just talking about
uh transformers for uh music and audio
which is very different than what all of
this were uh doing this past course um
i'm also the only speaker from stanford
so i have to do a good job so you see
like very good slides uh because i'm
kind of representing the university in
some sense
so yeah so the flow of the talk for
today is basically like i'll be throwing
a lot of stuff
it's kind of like a buffet style and
then you feel free to like or dislike
whatever you want
and i'll be talking mostly about like
three papers of what i've been working
on
uh
i'll start with like introducing like
what transformers are from a different
perspective uh what audio
representations are
uh
talk about uh uh generating model for
audio which is just doing like language
modeling on sample level
uh then i'll talk about how how can one
do like language modeling uh for speech
and audio which is different than what
people do for text
uh what are the current trends in the uh
literature
finally i'll
briefly mention uh similar stuff as to
what was happening in computer vision
with regard to vision transformers how
can we adapt similar ideas for audio
transformers and throw in a bit of
signal processing to improve the
performance
having told that the talk is about 35 to
40 minutes with about 15 minutes of q a
i should also say that all of the
opinions are mine and stanford or any
other professor is not responsible for
any of the mistake which i do
um
so the transformers kind of uh have kind
of revolutionized in a way like everyone
was approaching deep learning uh
before that it was all about cnns uh and
mostly uh all of these prominent models
have been coming in waves so there was a
time when everyone was just applying
cnns
then came a time where people started
adopting cnns and some sort of like
dilated confusions and slowly the
recurrent networks were getting out of
fashion
uh now it seems like transformers and
fashion all the time so it seems to be
solving almost every single problem
which is being thrown at them
um
so so what's special about it
uh one of the fact which struck me uh
was their simplicity
which is uh
if you think about it uh this uh
and it has been like hugely popular also
so uh it was just released in 2018 and
within three years it has like about 30
000 citations and it is kind of solving
every single problem in every single
domain
um it has its limitations though also
but if you think about it in a way
transformers are basically like a way of
like just cascading self attention with
feature learning and if you keep on
doing it over and over again
then the model in a way learns which
parts of the input are important and
keep on transforming them removing the
contents which are not important and
just to have the limited information
which is just responsible for a
particular task
and it has been very very difficult to
keep up with the literature you know
like uh uh i i have put it as a joke
here but then even twitter's
recommendation engine were kind of just
getting out of uh like they were getting
haywire as to like why is chris manning
just searching over transformers uh that
and that was way back in 2020
um so it has been like difficult for
researchers also to keep up with the
pace of what's going on
uh just before
transformers all of the nlp community
was just doing gaga about like
bi-directional listings with attention
so every single paper before 2017 was
just like you have encoded lstm layers
you keep on adding like multiple layers
and then after that you have a attention
mechanism which just learns at what's
important and then just keeps on
decoding sequentially one at a time
but this was not a kind of like an ideal
way to do it you know because
what turns out is when we start throwing
in longer sequences
uh the connections are no longer uh
storing the gradient updates in a way it
should be doing so what what the
researchers from google said you know
like instead of having just a tension
layer at the very last
um
encoding we would just have these
attention mechanisms at every single
layer which in a way would just learn
what's important for a particular
problem at that particular layer and we
keep on doing it over and over again
so so then then the whole idea of like
transformers and attention mechanism
cascaded one after the other came
uh and i'm not going to the details
because this is the last class of the
course uh but then usual tricks do help
across the neural net literature which
is like having multi-year retentions
um
having skip connection and layer norms
so all of these string things they are
not only like
giving gains for transformers themselves
but they can be just applied to any
single uh other architecture also
uh
the other thing which is helping this
research is basically the compute bar is
getting better and better
so so uh
all of these big companies are just
throwing massive amounts of computing
resources at uh solving very very simple
and trivial tasks
um the the top of the hill being like
the switch transformer which was
discussed in the course also
but but one of the thing which i think
started all of this trend was elmo which
was just learning these contextualized
representations for natural language
processing and that model right here was
perhaps one of the first
um
uh
kind of like
like model
0.0 or something or 0.1 in terms of like
bringing and ushering in the whole
revolution
you can see that how similar these kind
of models look like um bird was
basically like
inspired heavily from elmo
uh in which they just replaced all of
these lstm layers with transformer
modules
um so so a point to note also is like
irrespective of like natural language
processing or other domain these can be
adapted in a variety of domains and for
the today's talk i'll be just adapting
them to uh audio
so i'll basically start with
introducing people what audio
representations are and just for the
sake of completeness
talk about spectrograms
so spec like you can take any time
domain signal and
you can decompose that signal into
uh
a variety of uh basis functions and if
you take up a fourier transform you're
kind of like
uh
decomposing the actual time domain
signal into its sinusoidal basis
components so if you have like a
waveform here like this which is a sum
of three pure sinusoids
then their sum basically is this and you
can see that when you take a fourier
transform and its magnitude
you kind of have their strength of the
individual components
shown here
so you can take up another waveform
let's say a square wave
and what you have is basically a much
richer sinusoidal decomposition because
it is kind of a discontinuous signal so
you need like many more sinusoids to
represent that particular signal uh as
close to the actual signal as possible
and here also you can see that okay if
this was a square wave then it is
actually made up of uh
a lot of sinusoids where each of the
bar here represents the strength of the
particular sinusoid
from an optimization perspective i mean
this right away is uh suboptimal right
because you're kind of fixing up
uh the number of sinusoids you're using
for representing a square wave i would
have rather
used a basis function which it was a
square wave itself than a
sinusoidal signal right the second thing
is like even if we are taking a sinusoid
signal uh
we kind of are just
putting them in an equidistant space so
you're kind of dividing the whole
frequency access into like uh
equidistant bins and each of the bins is
responsible for like a particular
sinusoid a lot
so so that is like a traditional fourier
representation for representing any
signal
what we do for uh
uh
what a spectrogram suspect like but in
reality uh all of these signals are
discontinuous uh all of these signals
vary quite a bit right so you can have
like a signal while i'm speaking uh
which is like a square for a certain
period of time and then it gets
sinusoidal and then it becomes something
else so what we really need is like in a
way to
kind of like uh take patches of the
input signal and take fourier transform
of these individual patches
uh i'm deliberately using the word
patches but you can like in traditional
terms you're windowing the signal
uh you so right here you can see that
you you have a continuous signal you
keep on windowing it
you apply the fourier transform and what
you get is basically like a spectrogram
representation of the signal
so right here what you're seeing
basically is for each of the slices
the signal kind of looked like this
after taking the fourier transform of
the waveform which is there below
uh and what you do is for spectrogram
representation you keep on stacking
these uh fourier transform slides the
magnitude of the fourier transform
slices and in this way you kind of get
like a 2d representation of audio
segments
and if you are coming from a vision
background it is basically all of the
things which you are doing in vision
would just work well if you just apply
them to these 2d spectral
representations
i'll quickly play how these spectrograms
look like for a wide var area of like
common sounds
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay
so you could see like uh for
spectrograms you have kind of like a
time access on your x-axis and then you
have a frequency axis on y-axis
and then for whatever is your signal of
interest you're basically like putting
these slices together and different
sound gives you like different spectral
representations so it's kind of a vision
problem
just in this sort of like fourier space
um
so so there can be like different kinds
of representations also so uh one you
you could you could just take these uh
slices of fourier transform and then do
like a linear mapping to them uh so that
you are kind of in a way uh making these
as close to how humans here so you can
have like a log of the frequency on the
y axis instead of common frequency and
then you get like a constant q like
representation the advantage of this
being like you can see that for
different frequencies the the spacing
between the harmonics kind of remains
same so if you're like training
convolutional filters then that's of a
huge advantage because the signal like
one component of the invariance is gone
and you can just learn these filters
which are catching on to these constant
templates of
fourier slices uh you can have l filter
bank coefficients or you can have like
uh
the raw waveform also
for raw waveforms basically there are
two things which have we have to keep in
mind
one is the sampling rate so we kind of
like take the continuous signal and then
we discretize the continuous signal
so
one way one parameter is like how fast
we are sampling the continuous signal so
that's typically on the order of like 16
000 or 8 000 times a second if you're on
telephonic speech the other thing which
we also is like how how many levels we
are dividing your vertical axis so in
this case you can see that each of the
dots is basically one level and
typically people use eight bit
quantizers for 16-bit quantizers so in a
way you can think about that for every
one second of audio which we would hear
you would have like sixteen thousand
samples and then uh and each of the
sixteen thousand samples are allowed to
take one of the levels between zero to
fifty five
um and that's like if i can like take
the problem of like continuous audio and
just have it in terms of like this sort
of like discrete space then basically
like i'm just going to the territory of
like doing language modeling
um
so so for the first papers i discussed
is uh how can we do like uh
generative modeling for raw audio uh
which is similar to wavenets uh using
transformers uh i'll be putting qr codes
if you like the stuff what i'm doing and
if you
think that this is relevant to you
please cite or please uh have a look in
terms of like the qr codes
um
so yeah so i'll start with the first uh
sub sub topic of the today's talk which
is like
uh
what are uh
what are wavelets and
how do we do like this generating
modeling with raw audio
um so in single word you can think about
this as doing like language modeling
over these 255 states of audio so you
can throw in your
favorite transform model like
transformer excel or
gpt or whatever you want to call it
uh and just treat the problem as if
you're trying to predict one of the
levels out of 255 and you have to
predict the next level given a certain
context
uh that's what wavenet was doing so uh
the way you are modeling the uh
probability distribution of a continuous
space is basically you're trying to
predict what what's the probability of
the next sample given some parts context
and wavelet has been like hugely popular
because it has over 3000 citations and
it has been a core building block for
almost like all uh speech and audio
related problems like you can think
about like speech-to-text text-to-speech
synthesis uh instrument conversion uh
packet loss concealment over the
internet uh speech denoising so wherever
there is some sort of element of
modifying audio people have been using
wavenet um as a code building block
and raw waveform synthesis has been
difficult because just the magnitude of
the
problem if i'm just trying to synthesize
10 seconds of audio it would just amount
to like
me having a probability distribution
over 160 000 samples
um
and
that itself is tough because our ears
are very very sensitive to subtle
changes if i'm
off by one pixel in an image the image
like my eyes would not be as
as susceptible to noticing that effect
versus like if i'm off by say a few
pixels few samples in an audio it will
just catch our ears pretty quickly uh
people have been trying raw audio
synthesis a lot in the past
and before all of the wavenet and
transformer based approaches
kind of like wave rnns and sample rnns
were kind of like a
like state-of-the-art models
on the right i've seen i've shown a
sample rn model which kind of like uh
models the probability distribution of
what's going to come next given the past
at multiple levels
and and this was a work done by yoshia
benji at mila but you can
closely see like if you just see this
architecture versus a transformer
architecture in a way these are like
starting to get very very similar
because what you're trying to do is that
for for the probability distribution
here you're trying to see a lot of like
local substructures and then you keep on
doing it over and over again and you can
draw parallels like okay attention
mechanism should also kind of be doing
the same thing
so
this was the this was the uh kind of
like the literature in the past
what we tried to do was uh we just had
like the wavenet model and we tried to
see whether the transformers can beat
them and our intuition was like it
should be able to beat them because uh
they are successful all over the uh
other other domains like in language
modeling so it should it should do that
for raw waveforms also
uh we also try to see whether we can
circumvent the order n square constraint
uh by
conditioning or the context itself
uh and uh
like we did not go through specific
applications and we just said okay just
in terms like modeling behavior how well
they do
um
so so the data set for this was just
like real world channel recordings so so
so actual uh
uh
sound should not matter because like the
the model is agnostic to what it is
being thrown in
and the setup was exactly the same like
you are giving a certain context and i
have to predict like the next sample you
do the same thing with uh wavenets you
do the exact same thing with uh
transform based like gpt kind of like a
model and see how well they do
uh
i'll briefly chat about like what
wavelet models are
so wavelet was kind of like a
convolutional based model which was
getting rid of like all of the vanishing
gradient problem by just treating a
sequential problem as being learned by a
convolutional model
so what what they did was basically like
have this sort of like dilation layers
or like a conclusion with dilations
which is basically like i kind of skip
in every subsequent layer by one sample
so you can see like if i have a
dilation factor of two with a kernel
size of two i would get this kind of a
topology where my convolutional filters
in the very first layer are just like
combining the first two samples then i
skip by one in the next layer
and then i skip by three which is like i
look at like the fourth one in the next
layer and so on
uh the loss is still the same so i have
this network i learn a latent space and
then i have like a cross and categorical
cross entropy loss which is basically i
have to predict
the next sample given the previous one
um
and i i just do the exact same thing
with transformers also so so but then i
i have to make sure that i do it in a
causal manner so i have something which
is very similar to gpt in which i have
cause and masks in my attention
mechanism and i keep doing it over and
over again so so you have like uh
self-attention after that your feet
forward layers you just have a stack of
these uh transfer blocks and see how
they do
so so i said intuitively it should work
so
uh
like it should be doing better than like
our
base wavenet models right because if you
if you look at the topology
we are kind of defining a topology on
our own right so uh what what if like
the the current prediction i'd say layer
one world to depend on like very like uh
way back
uh sample say
instead of the second sample the tens
happens so we are kind of ignoring all
of that topology uh which would have
been important for prediction of this
particular task whereas uh transformers
with the self-attention mechanism can
just learn like okay which part of the
samples are important and which are not
and you can keep on doing iteratively uh
so it made sense to us that okay
transform layer should be doing way
better than wavelet models
the second thing which we came across
was like okay we cannot have a lot of
context for example the attention
mechanism needs to store all of those
uh of order n squares in this case if
i'm like storing data at 100
milliseconds then i have like about 1600
samples
and i need to store 1600 by 1600 at
multiple layers and it just becomes like
a huge
uh
problem with the data
problem with the memory constraint so so
what we said was okay uh what if we just
use the context itself as a latent code
so so in order to like
have like much better uh
uh representation at every layer we
cannot have like huge big attention
matrices so what we said was we would
just do it sample wise conditioning and
through a cnn layers just to understand
what the latent code would be so you
still have like an attention mechanism
or just a past context but then i'm also
conditioning at every sample
okay what what the next sample should be
given on this point context embedding
and if you think about it in a way it is
like okay if there are like five or six
notes being played in a piano then i'm
kind of certain which notes will be
played to a certain extent if i just
throw in a cnn layer uh so i'll use that
information along with what my transfers
are
are learning and then i would condition
it and i would just use that to predict
an example
so so for the evaluation criteria we did
not look for negative log likelihood
scores
uh we just looked at how well our
prediction prediction task was
so we took up like
stack wavenet which was implemented by
deepmind and saw that okay what was the
performance uh using their benchmarks
and even like bigger uh stacked wavenets
uh we then took started to increase the
complexity of transformers and started
to see whatever we we had proposed in
terms like conditioning on uh
on the vanilla transformer architectures
to see how they do
we did not look for like an application
specific
uh problem which is basically like uh we
don't look at like how well perceptual
tasks are for like say text to speech
synthesis or speech denoising we just
look at okay if we are trying to model
this using a cross entropy laws then
with the same model with the same a loss
function
how will they do on like similar kind of
parameters
uh so so this was the first kind of like
sub block of like how can we use our
transformers for generative modeling
for the second problem uh i'll i'll do a
quick head away on uh
how can we use like transformers for
doing language modeling which which is
kind of becoming a really fancy term
right now
um and this work was done by julia smith
uh way back in 2020 and
uh the goal of this was can we kind of
in a way do language modeling with
continuous audio uh sequences
uh and i'll briefly mention about that
in this part of some
in this sub-block of the talk
uh
so so and this is in regard for like
solving acoustic scene understanding
which is basically like
uh
if i'm given a chunk of audio then i
want to understand what's in there
and if we could do that
uh
well
then in a way we can do a lot of fancy
nice applications so for example like if
you think about like self-driving cars
so vmware has started to incorporate uh
microphones into the self-driving cars
uh why because say if there is an
ambulance coming or if there is a
fire truck coming then that sound would
be picked up
way way before even than the lidars or
even their sensors so they want to
understand that and take actions based
upon that
apple during covet did a hand washing
detection on their apple watch because
if you could detect when someone is
washing their hands then you can in a
way like
tell people that oh you need to wash
hands for 20 seconds and then
that that can be built upon as a cool
application
it can be used for uh music
recommendations so spotify youtube music
kind of gives like very very good
songs which you are listening to which
are similar in content
that you would perhaps like
um it can also give like really cool
applications like say people have tried
like detecting depression from audio
or i could detect whether i'm coughing
or not or i'm sneezing or not and these
can be like good
medical device medical applications
which can be used along with the current
diagnosis what doctor provides
so so the so the question was basically
for us was like how can we do like a
language modeling in a continuous audio
domain uh and secondly like how can we
train models or how should we approach
uh doing this
um
so so this kind of like recipe has
become like very very popular these days
in terms of like how would you approach
this problem it started with like
open ai and to a certain extent deep
mind proposing that in terms like we qva
models
but it turns out like transformers love
operating in discrete spaces as of now
and what they kind of do is
as long as your representations are
discreet they are very very good at
modeling what's going to come next
um
so so what people have been proposing as
a workaround is
uh
you could take up like
your your uh
favorite embedding in some manner you
can take a bqe embeddings or you could
take a wave to vector uh
in terms of video you can just do
uh
classic vgg or
resonant embeddings
you can apply k-means clustering to it
and k-means clustering would give you
like discrete codes
you do language modeling with those
discrete codes
and you predict the next code
and in a way if you're doing this then
you're kind of doing language modeling
or audio
and if you need to get back to the audio
then
you already saw with wavenet that you
can condition the wavenet model to give
continuous output so you can use those
codes to get back to the audio similar
to what jukebox and open eye did
[Music]
so so i'll quickly uh mention about like
what vector quantization is
uh
it's it's one of the most like
underutilized algorithms to be honest
and what it does is basically gives
in a way discrete codes to continuous
embedding spaces
so how do how does it do it so you
basically
have
a
embedding space let's say in 2d right
here you define what what are the number
of clusters you want to
put each of them in you run k memes and
you would certainly get these uh
patches of like where all of these
embeddings are what would be the
representative embedding of a continuous
embedding you can take all of those
patches and you can see you can just
number them or you can just like list
them
so in this case you can perhaps have
like 25 numbers or 20 numbers which are
like in a way mapping from a continuous
embedding to a discrete token
uh
this is another example right here so uh
in our case what we did was uh we took a
batches of spectrogram which are
basically like a very small uh
patches across time and then shared all
across the frequency axis
you take those patches you learn
embedding representation in our case it
was just like three layer auto encoder
fully connected encoders with three
layers of decoders and have a bottleneck
layer in between
so so that bottleneck layer basically is
kind of similar to this kind of diagram
in like say 64 dimensional space or 128
dimensional space
you take up those bottleneck codes and
then you run k-means clustering on it
suddenly in a way you can find uh
discrete codes for
continuous embedding spaces or even
container signals uh and since we know
that transformers kind of love operating
discrete spaces you can just apply
language modeling now and then you can
see what you can do
so in our case we just had like very
simple uh
three layer fully connected auto encoder
small patches uh the number of codes is
important because if you have like too
many codes
then you're kind of just throwing in all
kinds of noisy things now i'll give an
example of like
why the number of codes are important
through some example and you have like
two little codes
what you're in a way doing is you're
removing all of the information which
was relevant and you're just kind of
like averaging them all out um
[Music]
i i'll start with like so so this idea
first was uh
uh proposed by jukebox which which did
it for music
so so you do the exact same thing what i
talked about in a slightly different
manner uh in a way that okay you cannot
learn uh
codes for like longer sequences so you
know in a way learn sequences which are
just moving slowly and which are uh
looking at only a certain amount of
audio so kind of encode this in these
discrete levels which are basically like
uh
all of these basically are codes so at
every point i define like okay this
audio had perhaps like code number 55
and in the next level perhaps it had
code number two and the very top perhaps
you tried code number two thousand
um so in a way i'm like discretizing the
whole codes
uh now what i do is i take up my
favorite transform model perhaps like a
causal or autoregressive one and i say
that okay given these codes
try to predict what codes would come
next and for sure transformers can do
that
so i would generate the course in the
future
once i have generated the codes in the
future
i can say that okay this problem now is
kind of like a text-to-speech problem
right because i have like these discrete
words text-to-speech in a way is uh
going from discrete letters to
continuous audio
so i would throw in like the fanciest
which was wavenet and i would just get
back the code and i would get the
generated audio
so this was
in a way what i described uh that they
take up a continuous audio
they have these compressed codes which
they encode using a cnn in this case
um the the method doesn't matter you can
throw in like the fanciest of like
embedding or latent representation on
those
continuous code you generate the
patterns which are like what's going to
happen next in the future and then you
decode back using a
fancy wavenet or state-of-the-art model
um
so so this was what they were doing uh
for music synthesis
uh what we said was you know like uh
yeah this is good this can generate a
good amount of music but what can can
can these worlds be used for
generating uh
like good representation of the current
audio uh
and the goal there was like can language
models learn representation which can
just encapsulate whatever
uh we are kind of like giving as an
input signal
um so in this case what we tried after
that was kind of like uh
you you kind of do exactly kind of
similar ideas but uh instead of doing
like on wikivae end-to-end learned
encodings we just apply vanilla k-means
clustering similar to what i described
earlier
we do and spectrogram patches so you
take up these spectrograms of audio and
you just divide them into like very
small chunks
learn uh
auto encoder encodings for each of those
chunks
run crea means clustering in this case
like let's say i am learning 16 codes
uh represent the continuous audience in
terms of the 16 codes
um have a transformer which can perhaps
predict the next code and if i keep on
getting better and better at predicting
what's going to happen next
then in this linear layer i should be
encapsulating
what's important or what's
a good summary of what has happened in
the past
so so that was kind of like our
intuition behind trying this
and as i explained like the number of
quotes play a very important role uh you
can see here
these are just two piano notes switching
one after the other if i just have like
say 16 number of quotes it just
happens to have just a single line of
encoding a single code assigned to all
of this whereas if i'm assigning like
more codes then it becomes kind of like
a fine-grained prediction where i'm
actually able to get what the individual
nodes are
recently facebook also said you know
like okay they just had a different name
to the whole uh thing which is uh
we would we can just call this as text
less and it'll be also in the sense that
okay you can do nlp
without having access to text
but the idea is very very similar you
have an encoder which is exactly similar
to say what openai was using you have a
bqba wave to vect or whatever you want
to do you can apply k-means clustering
to it they apply language models to it
and instead of a decoder being variant
they just have a decoder which is like a
different version of text-to-speech
which is like taco drawn in this case so
as you can see like these are all like
same wine and very different bottles but
the core idea is almost exactly the same
so so this was like a it created a huge
uh a prayer of like oh this is going to
change in lpn but this is very similar
to what
people have been doing in the past
[Music]
so so i've already explained what uh
what this was
uh
so so in our case we just try to predict
what's going to happen next given the
previous context and use that
representation similar to every single
uh
like one-shot learning or zero-shot
learning based uh method
uh
i also explain like why the number of
codes are important like if you have too
small then you're just throwing a lot of
information if you have too large then
you don't
put in like
it is not no longer robust to noise
um
so so this was our setup and uh before i
jump in i should add one of the tweets
which i uh
uh
saw from one of the most prominent
researchers i deep mind which is
basically like a lot of times it is very
very easy to bump up numbers you know
like i can i can have these details just
not present in my paper which which
actually helped a lot in terms of like
improving the performance and kind of
sometimes don't take into account
what the actual model is
uh incorporating or what model is
contributing versus
what the actual these tricks for
training are incorporating so for most
of these methods what we are trying to
see is we try to keep almost exactly the
same approach no data augmentation no
fancy label smoothing or
moving average of weights or decay or
whatever you just have similar based
recipes uh to see how well we are doing
so for this case we the the goal was to
say that how well our models do with
respect to this purely supervised
approach and how well it does with
respect to a similar unsupervised
approach
uh so in the first case the model and
all of the weights are accessed to all
of the labels which which is just
uh shown as vgg supervised which is
basically you take up a audio
understanding data set and you you see
how well you are doing an accuracy
metrics
um
so that was the first one and the second
one we applied simclair which was
proposed by jeff intent in which you can
take up these multiple augmentations of
the same input you can have like patches
removed you can blur the signal you can
flip the signal uh you learn embedding
order the last layer without access to
the labels and then just have a linear
head to predict
what's happening
by using that we got a 55 percent
accuracy
uh you do the exact same thing with
transformers you don't have access to
labels you just run them while just
predict the next code uh you take the
linear layer apply the same linear head
and try to predict what's happening
inside and with that we got 60 accuracy
so even though the results are not good
but the fact is uh the neural networks
actually
are very very good at
uh
like getting better and better with
throwing of huge amounts of data right
so there is still 10 back gap between
like purely supervised and purely
unsupervised
um but then that that's going to improve
with throwing a lot of data to these
models because
it doesn't have access to any label last
person
so this is a famous paper by dan ellis
and nelson morgan at berkeley in which
they actually showed way back in 1999 as
to
why
uh
like size matters for deep neural
networks and also the number of uh data
points which is present so as they kept
on increasing the
size of the data set and the parameters
they kept on getting lower and lower
world error rates and this has been true
across
any of the data set and that's why the
whole excitement is about unsupervised
learning
uh so so this was in a way flavor of
like how can we do like language
modeling and unsupervised learning on uh
audio for continuous segments
uh for the third subplot i'll just
quickly mention uh
ideas which are very similar to what you
would have seen in vision transformers
but with the caveat that how can we
use some sort of like signal processing
to improve these performance mute
further
so so the basic approach still remains
the same exactly as what you would have
seen in vision transformers
you have
a
signal of interest which you want to
classify
here they are raw waveforms instead of
images the goal is to predict what's
there
inside of it right
uh
and also we don't have any conclusions
we don't have any other tricks which we
were using before all we have to do is
they can transformers themselves uh
solve this particular problem
um
so so for the data set uh and and the
whole setup was still the same uh no
data augmentation and no
other
forms of these tricks
you are given like 40 000 snippets for
training and 10 000 for validation
uh our job is to predict as as good as
possible as to what's there in the audio
uh this problem is very similar to the
the sound which you heard and the video
which you saw that given this patch you
have to predict given a spectrogram
patch you have to predict what's there
inside of it
uh
uh we we kind of do uh
uh one step further than what what
what's just like a simple transformer
model in a sense that we tried to see
whether some sort of like hierarchy over
uh uh transform mm radix would help us
in any manner
so for that we use like uh wavelet
decomposition on the intermediate
transformer embeddings
um so what is like a wavelet
decomposition uh
in very naive terms it can be like a way
of
decomposing
the intermediate embeddings into
another intermediate embedding in a
sense that we are kind of putting these
highways off like some embeddings are
moving very slowly and some membranes
are moving very fast and some remainings
are retained exactly at the rate of what
the original signal was
uh and why this is important because you
can think about that at every
intermediate state
you are in a way learning some sort of
hierarchy in the model so
uh if i if i if i look at what we do
with the
uh
like wavelet decomposition before and
after let's say like you had time across
this
and you had the embedding size across
this and this this whole patch was your
output of say the nth layer of the
transformer
what i say now is okay i would just
have a mapping from this
to the mapping of my interest using
wavelet decomposition
in which for half of the samples i just
retain the exact same embedding as what
what was learned by the transform model
in the next half i would start combining
two at a time so in a way i'm learning
this sort of like a t tree structure
within a single layer of the transformer
embedding uh and for now the the
the wavelet or the bc's function which i
use is simple averaging so let's say i
from all of the embedding layers in
between
i just need to have like one
one
uh
embedding which which is not moving at
all which is just representative
whatever is there
of the whole
a
um
space in that nth layer
then in the next next layer i would just
use like two at a time and then i would
use like four at a time
till i reach the exact resolution as
what i had
doing this operation doesn't add any
parameters whatsoever you're just like
defining what your basis function would
be or what your wavelet function would
be in this case it is a hard wavelet and
i start combining them and i kind of
like learned a hierarchy at every single
layer of the transformers
um and
this kind of like
improved our performance significantly
as compared to not using them with
addition of no extra parameters
um and i'll come to the results later
also
so so this is how the whole approach
looks like
you have a front end uh the front end is
basically
a single layer of 2000 neurons
followed by a dense
layer of 64 neurons which is just to
make sure
to
uh
conform it to the intermediate
transformer readings let's say if for
the transformers i define the embedding
size to be 64
then that's the dimension which i'm like
mapping them to
so i take a broad waveform i patch it in
like very small patches similar to how
you're doing vision transformers
i would just have a single layer of 2000
neurons followed by a dense layer of 64
neurons
with the hope that the first layer kind
of is learning like a fourier basis
function
uh which should be adaptable according
to what i'm learning
after that
i keep on doing this over and over again
like i i don't have a classification
head or anything like that
i i keep on adding multiple stacks of
transformers after that
but
uh
and then i have two two approaches of
like what i can do in terms of like
uh adaptation i can do average pulling
across time of these intermediate
temperatures because that is very the
idea is very similar to what we did do
in classical vision that each of the
embeddings are looking at much much
broader
uh output in the subsequent layers or i
could do a
wavelet decomposition so what i do is
that i i take all of these embeddings
and i define these highways so some of
the embeddings are moving fast some of
them are moving very slow and some are
retained at the exact same resolution as
what the transformer is learning
and then i keep doing this over and over
again i have a dense layer
i have my soft max or sigmoid whatever
is my classification head
so so this is kind of what the approach
looks like
we compare it with
uh all of the traditional vision uh
based architectures so so the vision
based models have been very good
and the performance have been like
similar in understanding audio also so
we compare all of those models in terms
like mean average precision
and we see that even the tiniest models
of transformers were just like
surpassing all of the state-of-the-art
cnn waters which was a very good sign
then we started to bump up okay the
larger model should keep on improving
the performance and with the
multi-scale models as well as with the
pooling layers
they improve the performance even
further
which which was kind of very surprising
to us because the number of parameters
are very small these are very tiny
architectures yet they are surpassing
like things like even densenet which are
like huge models with a lot of millions
of parameters
um
so so after that we said uh that i'm
going to conclude quickly
after that we said that okay this is
this is looking pretty cool
uh
what are the actual what actually is the
transformer or the first layer learning
right
so
uh in order to
make this plot what we said was
okay uh if you were to take a classic
fourier transform
then if my this axis is kind of like
freak like frequency
uh this axis is the number of filters
and this axis is the frequency
then in a way
it should be
connecting
all of the points in a linear line
and this is akin to the number of points
in the 50. so how many points i'm
defining here if i'm defining 2000
points here then i would have like 2048
sinusoidal basis functions which are
going from lower frequency to the most
highest frequency
we said okay we'll do the exact same
thing but now with filters
so we have a frequency along y-axis and
the number of points in my x-axis and if
it was a classic fourier transform then
it would be connecting right as a linear
line
um but what we did was
we we take up the
front end which is known by transformer
take its fourier transform sort
according to its center frequency as to
what frequency it is actually activating
the most and then keep on stacking them
uh when we did this for two problems we
saw that we are kind of learning a
different
time frequency representation which is
specific to a predictive problem so if
i'm trying to understand what's there in
the content of the audio i learn a
representation which is very different
than fourier transform which would have
been a straight line which is kind of
like a
curved exponential line like this
and if i do like a polyphonic pitch
estimation
i learn a very different
front end which is adapting to that
particular problem so this was like very
exciting to us because
uh
like making computers here in a way in
which they are adapting their ears
according to a particular problem is a
very cool idea
uh second thing is we actually saw each
of the filters as to what they were
doing
uh and
these are basically just like single
slices like this so so this is what
would we would have been learned as a
front-end neuron so we take up each of
the neurons and we just plot them and
for plotting this we basically take its
fourier transform and then
sort them according to where the center
frequency is
uh when we just saw the neurons as to
what they were learning in the front end
uh we saw that it is learning properties
which are very very
uh
closely matching with the traditional
signal processing so you would have
something like an answer detector
learned right here
you're learning windowing function so in
a way it is learning to
have a kernel which is best for a time
frequency representation what people
have been using in signal processing
which is like a hamming or a hanging
window
we are learning these pure sinusoids
which are responsible for
activating a particular frequency so you
can see the richness as compared to like
having a fixed purely sinusoidal basis
function right here
um so so this was what we had uh
uh done and then to share the final
thoughts um
uh i'll conclude by saying that okay
transformers are proving to be a major
advancement in ai research across the
fields
and
it seems like they're solving everything
for now uh and hopefully this is not the
end and we should keep an eye out on
something which would change and
have impact which is more than
what transformers have put
and who knows what's going to come next
uh
yeah so by that i'll just conclude and
i'll be happy to take questions
uh thank you pratik that was a really
good talk and you uh you provided some
really good insights about how like
transformers work for the audio case
and yeah
thank you for that
and now i would invite questions from
from the class students let me just stop
the recording